des Jeux Olympiques puisque c'est
l'actualité du Sénat cette semaine est
examinée ce texte sur l'organisation des
Jeux olympiques et paralympiques STIB on
va voir avec vous on va évidemment
parler de culture festival dans quelques
instants mais ça ça concerne aussi les
festivals puisque l'un des grands défis
de ces Jeux Olympiques ce sera le
maintien de la sécurité qu'est-ce qui
est prévu par le gouvernement une
innovation majeure à retenir moyenne les
caméras intelligentes concrètement des
algorithmes seront utilisés pour repérer
des comportements jugés anormaux ces
comportements seront automatiquement
signalés aux forces de l'ordre qui
décideront s'il faut s'il faut ou pas
intervenir la ministre assure que nos
libertés ne sont pas menacées par cette
innovation très critiquée par certaines
associations écoutez
nous avons entendu les questions sur la
nature de certains dispositifs comme le
traitement par algorithme des images de
la vidéoprotection qui continuent je le
sais d'interroger sur certains bancs de
cette émission mais nous voulons
souligner que les très nombreuses
garanties mises en place dans le cadre
de cette expérimentation nous aiderons à
être au rendez-vous de la sécurité des
jeux tout en préservant les droits et
libertés de nos concitoyens trois autres
grandes mesures sont prévues en matière
de sécurité le recrutement de 22000 à
33000 agents de sécurité privée
l'extension des pouvoirs du préfet de
police de Paris ses compétences seront
étendues aux quatre départements de la
grande couronne parisienne ou encore
l'utilisation de scanner corporel par
les gestionnaires des enceintes
sportives on voit déjà c'est scanner
dans les aéroports ils débarquent donc
dans les stades et des mesures
concernant les supporters seront
également examinés oui le fiasco du
Stade de France c'est encore dans toutes
les têtes plusieurs mesures tendons d'en
tirer les enseignements le texte prévoit
par exemple la création de deux nouveaux
délits pour sanctionner les intrusions
dans les enceintes sportives ils
prévoient également l'obligation de
recourir à des billets infalsifiables on
se souvient que lors de la finale de la
Ligue des Champions beaucoup de Freud
avait été constaté savait contribué au
désordre autour du stade le texte
prévoit enfin la facilitation des
interdictions de stade prévoit notamment
de rendre obligatoire ces interdictions
pour un certain nombre de délires merci
Steve on va évidemment parler de ce
texte est-ce que c'était un texte
indispensable pour le bon déroulement de
ces Jeux olympiques et paralympiques je
pense que ce texte était effectivement
indispensable après tout ce que nous
avons connu en France ou l'avait rappelé
les incidents au Stade de France les
intrusion sur des airs de compétition ce
texte est effectivement en plus le
dernier possible avant les Jeux
Olympiques parce que les Jeux Olympiques
auront lieu dans 18 mois et il faut les
préparer vous avez évoqué le manque de
personnel de sécurité il faut va falloir
les former très vite
donc plusieurs pistes ont été évoqués et
le grand apport de ce texte aussi à bord
du Sénat c'est effectivement
l'obligation d'avoir recours à des
billets nominatifs
dématérialisés et infalsifiable c'est
d'ailleurs c'était d'ailleurs la
recommandation numéro une du rapport des
présidents buffets et Lafont qui avaient
été présenté au mois de juillet suite
aux incidents
de la finale de la Ligue des Champions
ce texte permet que ce fiasco ne se
reproduise plus selon vous c'est une des
pistes une des pistes notamment ce sont
effectivement les billets et puis les
contrôles et les sanctions que nous
avons adopté hier soir Jean-Jacques
est-ce que ce texte était indispensable
et est-ce que surtout ce texte il les
opérationnel en matière de sécurité
est-ce que vous êtes rassuré pour la
sécurité des Jeux Olympiques avec ce
texte alors tout d'abord une observation
pour préciser que ce texte il arrive en
première lecture au Sénat alors que
habituellement les textes qui arrivent
en première lecture concerne les
territoires et concerne les
collectivités locales donc je crois que
c'est une marque de confiance vis-à-vis
du Sénat et nous devons effectivement
le rappeler alors je pense effectivement
que c'était un texte inévitable un texte
incontournable moi je voudrais rappeler
que depuis la candidature de la France
c'est-à-dire depuis 2015 maintenant on
savait très bien qu'il allait falloir se
conformer à tout un ensemble de
directives un certain nombre d'exigences
émanant du CO du Comité international
olympique en particulier le respect de
la Charte olympique les respects des
contrats de vie haute donc c'est tout
simplement la mise en œuvre des
contraintes imposées par ce type
d'événements qui restent un événement
hors-norme un événement tout à fait
exceptionnel d'où est tout un ensemble
de dérogation vis-à-vis du droit commun
qui se pose c'est est-ce qu'il va
falloir avoir recours à l'armée pour
pallier le manquement de force de
sécurité hier j'ai radarmanin dans
l'amitié qui vous a dit qu'il ne pouvait
pas vous dire encore si il y avait
besoin d'avoir recours à l'armée
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez on a senti
effectivement un petit peu d'hésitation
un petit peu de cafouillage de la part
du du ministre de l'Intérieur peut-être
qu'au plus haut niveau de l'État le
problème n'est pas encore tranché mais
il est bien évident que le recours à
l'armée pour des raisons de sécurité
c'est vraiment une hypothèse ultime
quand on se trouve dans un régime de
liberté dans un état de droit comme le
nôtre mais se pose effectivement le
recrutement en particulier des agents de
sécurité privée il en faudrait 22000 à
25000 d'ailleurs c'est l'une des mises
en garde qui avait été pointée il y a
quelques jours par Pierre Moscovici le
premier président de la Cour des comptes
en ce qui concerne aussi bien
l'organisation que le coût du système
sécuritaire pour vous il faut éviter ce
recours à l'armée où il faut avoir
recours à tous les moyens nécessaires
pour assurer cette sécurité comme le
disait Jean-Jacques il faut
effectivement c'est la dernière option
puisque recruter d'ici quelques mois
entre 22 voire 33
personnels pour assurer la sécurité lors
de cet événement ça paraît très
compliqué donc on est déjà obligé de
faire appel
aux sociétés de sécurité privée
effectivement mais l'armée c'est une des
hypothèses et comme nous l'a dit hier
soir Gérald Darmanin
cette hypothèse nous verrons son
effectivité
au mois de mars il pourra nous redonner
la réponse au mois de mars il y a une
mesure qui pose question et qui a
beaucoup interrogé qui a d'ailleurs été
voté cette nuit par les sénateurs c'est
l'autorisation d'expérimenter des
caméras dotées d'algorithme alors qui
pourrait détecter des mouvements de full
suspects aux abords des événements sur
les voies publiques ou d'autres
événements qui auraient un risque qui
présenterait un risque pour la sécurité
des personnes est-ce qu'on est dans un
tournant en matière de sécurité avec ses
caméras
je pense effectivement que nous sommes
dans un tournant c'est ce qu'on appelle
les caméras augmentaient
mais nous sommes effectivement dans un
tournant puisque ce type de sécurité est
aujourd'hui je pense inévitable donc
c'est un tournant nécessaire c'est un
tournant nécessaire puisque on repère
des mouvements de foule il n'y a pas
d'identification des personnes mais je
crois que ça c'est important
la question de la reconnaissance faciale
a été évitée parce que c'est un problème
qui ne peut pas être juste mis dans une
telle loi par voie d'amendement
cette si un jour on devrait avoir
recours effectivement à la
reconnaissance faciale il va falloir
passer par une série de débats
contradictoires et surtout par une loi
spécifique c'est un tournoi qui est
nécessaire aussi pour vous Jean-Jacques
ce qui est sûr c'est que c'est un
tournant qui est particulier à
l'évolution technologique et au recours
à cette évolution technologique dans
tout un ensemble de dispositifs
sécuritaire bon on savait pertinemment
qu'une grande partie du débat allait
porter sur cette question la
reconnaissance faciale mais à ce stade
la reconnaissance faciale n'est pas
présente dans dans le texte alors
effectivement on a beaucoup débattu sur
ces caméras intelligentes augmentées
c'est tout simplement l'application de
d'un nouveau système d'intelligence
artificielle appliquée à des mesures de
sécurité lors d'événements de cette
ampleur c'est là où on voit l'évolution
technologique de notre société vous
savez la dernière fois que la France a
organisé ces Jeux olympiques d'été
c'était en 1924 il y a un siècle est-ce
que les problèmes de sécurité se poser
de cette manière-là pas du tout et
notamment en raison d'abord de
l'importance qui a été prise depuis par
les Jeux Olympiques on attend quand même
13 millions de personnes en France pour
cette occasion là mais également en
raison de toute cette évolution
technique technologique scientifique et
donc on aura du mal à échapper à cela ce
qu'il faut veiller par contre c'est
effectivement faire en sorte que tous
ces nouveaux dispositifs là ne soient
pas attentats aux libertés individuelles
ce sont des dispositifs qui pourraient
être utilisé également pour les
événements culturels je vais pas vous
poser la question sur les stades de foot
mais pour les événements culturels
notamment ceux qui présentent un risque
d'attentat assez élevé est-ce que ça
vous inquiète ou ça vous rassure que ce
type de dispositif soit mis en place
alors ce que je relève dans ce que vous
venez dire c'est pourra et donc nous on
sera très vigilant en fait ce ne soit
pas une obligation de plus qui pèse sur
les organisateurs de manifestations
culturels parce que depuis justement les
attentats 2015 il y a eu un renforcement
très important de la sécurité
de nos manifestations dans des lieux
fermés comme dans les festivals donc
effectivement on suit ce qui se passe
actuellement au Sénat on espère
effectivement que ces mesures qui
pourraient perdurer au-delà des JO ne
soit soit des facultés et pas des
obligations parce que tout cela
complique l'organisation des
manifestations et n'oublions pas
également que ça présente un coup
nouveau aussi pour les organisateurs
donc on sera vigilant à cela voilà
comment vous pouvez répondre à
l'inquiétude de manière assez Guinot sur
sur le caractère obligatoire ou non et
sur le coup à qui reviendra la charge de
ces caméras quand on organise des
festivals par exemple alors tout
simplement répondre sur le pourra
effectivement ce n'est pas une
obligation et nous y avons veillé au
niveau du Sénat que ça ne soit que ça ne
représente pas une obligation pour les
organisateurs ni pour pour les
collectivités ce sera toujours basé sur
la partie volontaire à ce moment-là
c'est vrai qu'il y aura un coût ce coût
sera pris en
charge en partie sous forme d'aide par
l'État c'est ce qu'on nous a assuré hier
soir
par exemple
pour vous donner
pourcentage
c'est toujours la même chose on peut pas
donner le pourcentage
en ce qui concerne Paris c'est la
préfecture de police qui prend en charge
donc pas la ville de Paris c'est déjà
pas mal
il y a des conventions qui sont partis
avec certaines villes par exemple
Marseille l'État prend en charge 80% du
du coût de l'installation de tel caméra
parce que c'est vrai que post attentat
2015 on a eu un renforcement très fort
des factures des services d'or
d'indemnité avec des applications pas
toujours très cohérentes sur l'ensemble
du territoire donc oui pour nous c'est
c'est un niveau on est en vigilance
là-dessus voilà
vous pouvez la rassurer Jean-Jacques
[Rires]
je dirais que pour ceux qui nous
concerne nous avons essayé de faire
remonter vos attentes vos inquiétudes
vous les organisateurs de manifestation
culturel parce que il y a d'une part un
certain nombre de dispositions dans ce
texte et qui sont appelés à devenir
pérenne et qui donc sont des décisions
post-olympiques et qui vont concerner
aussi bien des manifestations
culturelles que des manifestations
sportives alors parfois il y aura une
évaluation parfois non parfois il y aura
une expérimentation parfois non mais on
sait très bien que ce sont des
dispositions qui sont appelés à
s'inscrire dans la dans la durée et
effectivement il y a je dirais des
difficultés très matérielles qui vont se
poser notamment en ce qui concerne le
coût et c'est la raison pour laquelle
d'ailleurs notre notre chef de fil
Sylvie Robert avait demandé la création
d'un comité de suivi national pour
assurer cette sorte de passerelle de
conciliation entre les entre d'un côté
les Jeux Olympiques et d'autres côtés la
préservation des événements culturels il
ne faut pas que tout cela se télescope
en particulier en termes de calendrier
bon là aussi le ministre de l'intérieur
a été rassurant hier puisqu'il nous a
annoncé que aucun événement culturel il
y avait été annulé il avait été supprimé
pas
tous
Jean-Jacques lazac pour la transition
puisqu'on va parler des conséquences de
l'organisation de ces Jeux Olympiques
sur les festivals pour concentrer les
forces de l'ordre sur les JO certaines
manifestations sportives culturelles
pour être annulées ou reporté après des
années difficiles en 2020 et en 2021 à
cause du covid les organisateurs de ces
événements culturels craignent que l'été
2024 soit affectée par l'organisation de
cgio et le passage de la flamme
olympique selon l'exécutif
l'organisation des grands événements
pourrait être incompatibles avec les
Jeux Olympiques on regarde ce portage de
Flora sauvage et je vous fais réagir
juste après 30 000 policiers des
gendarmes seront mobilisés chaque jour
pour sécuriser les Jeux Olympiques qui
se tiendront du 18 juillet au 11 août et
les Jeux paralympiques du 24 août au 8
septembre de période où policiers et
gendarmes ne pourront pas assurer la
sécurité des grands festivals culturels
l'annonce en octobre dernier a eu
l'effet d'une douche froide le ministre
de l'Intérieur Gérald Darmanin a dévoilé
au Sénat le dispositif de sécurité
pour les JO à l’été 2024
événements en France qui demande des
unités de force mobile en qui demandent
voilà la présence serait forte de nombre
de policiers on pense à des grands
festivals culturels comme le Festival
d'Avignon ont déjà annoncé qu'ils
avanceraient leurs dates pour démarrer
dès le 29 juin afin de ne pas empiéter
sur les JO d'autres comme rock en scène
qui a lieu le dernier week-end d'août ne
peuvent pas reporter leur festival à une
date ultérieure la tenue de rencontre ce
week-end là elle s'explique par
l'existence de festivals importants qui
attire eux-mêmes des artistes importants
et des stars internationales sur
d'autres territoires et notamment en
Angleterre ici ces forces ne sont pas
disponibles et si on ne peut pas assurer
la sécurité c'est notre capacité à tenir
et à organiser sa manifestation qui est
en jeu pour les organisateurs il y a
urgence à obtenir des réponses car sans
feu vert des autorités il n'est pas
possible de lancer la programmation et
une absolue nécessité d'avoir des
réponses claires rapidement de pouvoir
acter dans les mois qui viennent que le
festival pourra avoir lieu on va pas
signer un contrat avec un artiste si
quelques mois après on a un risque de
devoir annuler la manifestation
mi-décembre une circulaire
interministérielle a précisé la feuille
de route pour l'organisation des grands
événements sportifs ou culturels pendant
les JO les organisateurs son sommet de
travailler au cas par cas avec les
préfets comme l'explique Sylvie Robert
rapporteur du budget de la culture au
Sénat ça va être en quelque sorte à la
discrétion en fonction de la réalité
territoriale des préfets et donc en
fonction de ce qui va se passer aussi au
niveau d'un certain nombre de festival
les préfets vont pouvoir dire oui c'est
possible parce que j'ai encore des
unités de force mobile où ça n'est pas
possible autre crainte le risque de voir
certains festivals annulés à la dernière
minute notre vigilance c'est savoir si
les engagements qui ont été pris par les
différents préfets fin mars 2023 est-ce
que les autorisations ne sont pas
sujettes à un retour en arrière
au à l'approche des Jeux Olympiques des
Jeux Olympiques ça fait 7 ans qu'ils
sont attribués donc le manque
d'anticipation de leur côté nous pose
question si les discussions sont en
cours pour permettre au festival d'avoir
lieu malgré la tenue des JO se pose
aussi la question des concerts qui ont
lieu habituellement au Stade de France
ou à l'accord Arena réquisitionné à
l'occasion pour les JO sans compter le
manque à gagner pour les organisateurs
des festivals menacés d'annulation
l'État devra mettre en place des
procédures d'indemnisation assure les
professionnels ne seront impactés par
les Jeux Olympiques que les festivals
qui habituellement ont recours à des
unités de force mobile c'est à dire des
des CRS ou des escadrons des escadrons
de gendarmerie donc déjà ça limite
considérablement le nombre de festivals
qui devrait être concernés par les Jeux
Olympiques ce qui ce qui c'est à dire ce
sont des festivals de grandeur ce sont
majoritairement des festivals de grande
ampleur donc effectivement il en reste
plus beaucoup sur le territoire en plus
il vous regardez les périodes concernées
et les dates concernées parce que la
séquence des JO a été découpée en quatre
en quatre en quatre périodes c'est ce
qui est indiqué dans la circulaire
interministériale du mois de décembre
envoyer au préfet et donc à ce qu'on
appelle les zones rouges celles durant
la période des Jeux Olympiques et durant
la période des Jeux paralympiques et
notamment c'est le cas de rock en scène
mais également sur la période de la
période rouge sur le territoire parisien
on a Lola paluza pour ses festivals non
seulement il y a recours à l'unité de
force mobile mais en plus ils sont sur
les dates extrêmement compliquées
puisque en conflit immédiat avec la
période des Jeux Olympiques donc les
discussions sont en cours ce qu'on sait
aujourd'hui c'est que les discussions
continuent nous on a vraiment besoin
d'avoir une visibilité assez rapidement
puisque comme l'ont rappelé les
organisateurs de festivals les
programmations elles se font à partir de
début d'année 2023 pour l'édition 2024
ils engagent énormément de de fonds de
de budget quand il les engage et quand
ils mettent en place des Festivals il y
a effectivement la programmation
artistique mais derrière il y a tout
tout le côté matériel donc effectivement
il faut qu'on soit stabilisé très vite
surtout surtout il faut une
stabilisation des décisions jusqu'au
jour J parce que 2024 c'est proche
maintenant c'est encore loin donc on
espère véritablement que les décisions
écrites seront seront tenues jusqu'au
jour J après on restera vigilance sur
tout ce qui se passe néanmoins sur
l'ensemble du territoire français
puisque la circulaire nous donne un
cadre nous dit que normalement les
autres festivals ne devraient pas être
impactés néanmoins on restera vigilant
et c'est aussi pour cela qu'on avait
sollicité un comité de suivi au niveau
national pour pouvoir nous assurer que
les décisions prises sur le territoire
français serait cohérentes en tout cas
la chose pour l'instant on l'a
effectivement pas été entendu nous
savons que des sénateurs sont au soutien
de cette demande on n'a pas été entendu
en tout cas il faut quand même noter le
côté positif c'est qu'entre la
l'intervention du ministre de
l'Intérieur en octobre qui purement est
simplement nous indiquer qu'il fallait
que les festivals n'existent pas en 2024
parce qu'il y avait la séquence Jo on a
progressé le fait festivalier a été
traité et on a reconnu que festival et
sport devait cohabiter sur la séquence
2024 ce matin vous êtes plus rassuré que
vous ne les tiens quand vous avez
entendu Gérard Dahman j'ai clairement
mais néanmoins je ne voudrais pas croire
que tout tout doux est levé et qu'il
faut encore aujourd'hui avoir des
garanties et dernière chose et vous
l'avez dit nous serons très vigilants au
festival qui nous pourront pastenir qui
ne pourront pas trouvé un autre site qui
ne pourront pas trouvé d'autres dates
parce que là en effet il y a un
démonisation du préjudice subi à prendre
en considération il y a la perte pour
l'organisateur la perte pour les
artistes pour les techniciens c'est
autant d'heures de travail non payé des
droits d'auteur qui ne seront pas versés
des taxes qui ne seront pas payés et
également cela a été dit n'oublions pas
que là on a fait un focus sur les
festivals mais il y a tout ce qui se
passe autour tous les Arenas et les
stats qui sont qui seront retenus pour
les manifestations sportives c'est
autant de lieux qui ne seront pas à
notre disposition pour organiser ce
qu'on appelle les concerts importants
des artistes français majeurs et des
artistes internationaux sur cette
période de l'année entre mai et
septembre c'est 50% du chiffre
d'affaires du secteur donc ça concerne
beaucoup de sites parisiens
il y a aussi à Lille le stade est
également un haut lieu de spectacle il y
a Marseille à Lyon on sait pas encore
comment ce sera ce sera possible donc on
va avoir une perte sèche au niveau de
notre secteur d'activité qui déjà peine
à rebondir deux ans après donc c'est des
discussions qu'on a pas encore eu la
possibilité d'ouvrir très franchement
elle a dit beaucoup de choses
à dire on va revenir un petit peu plus
en détail mais est-ce que vous aussi
vous êtes plus rassuré comme elle est
cassée Guinot que vous ne l'étiez en
octobre quand vous avez entendu Gérald
Darmanin ah bah quand nous avons entendu
le ministre de l'Intérieur en octobre
c'est vrai que nous étions un peu
je dirais presque fâché parce que nous
n'étions pas du tout au courant de ce de
cette affaire en fait c'était une sortie
un peu hasardeuse appelons là comme cela
de notre ministre mais c'est vrai que
dans la foulée avec Laurent Lafont nous
avons publié une tribune dans Le Monde à
ce sujet et aujourd'hui nous sommes un
peu plus rassurés pas complètement
rassuré est-ce que quelque part c'est
aussi pas ça qui a déclenché la suite
est-ce que s'il avait pas fait de cette
sortie on serait peut-être encore un peu
dans le flou je pense que la question
n'aurait pas été posée de la même
manière effectivement
ça réveillait quelques ça réveillait les
festivaliers ça révélé la ministre de la
Culture puisque elle-même était un peu
quoi ça réveillait le kojob puisque j'ai
eu l'occasion de discuter avec le
président du kojob qui m'a dit Tony
Estanguet il a dit mais jamais nous ne
voulons entrer en concurrence avec la
culture ce n'est pas notre notre
objectif et donc
finalement c'est peut-être merci Gérald
Darmanin quelque part
oui il faut surtout pas effectivement
que entre en concurrence en compétition
si je peux dire le sport et la culture
d'autant plus que le sport est un
phénomène de culturel sur cette
problématique de la coexistence de la
cohabitation entre les Jeux Olympiques
et puis d'autre part tout un ensemble de
manifestations culturelles il y a
effectivement ce problème de répartition
sur l'ensemble du territoire national
des forces de l'ordre ce problème de
calendrier qui qui se télescope mais il
y a aussi le fait que il faut pas être
naïf il y a des menaces qui sont
diffuses je dirais sur l'ensemble du
territoire national il s'agit pas
simplement de sécuriser les
localisations les lieux où se déroulent
les compétitions il n'y a pas que les
enceintes sportives à sécuriser mais
quasiment l'ensemble du territoire
national et puis aussi en matière de
sécurité vous savez l'une des menaces
les plus premium c'est aussi concerne
les cyberatas qu'on en parle très très
peu mais on l'a vu notamment au moment
des JO de pyongchang en 2018 il y a eu
des dessins intrusions dans le système
informatique de l'organisateur et
malheureusement nous ne sommes pas à
l'abri de ce type de réalité un mot sur
le calendrier de cette sortie Gérald
Darmanin c'était un petit peu moins de 2
ans avant l'organisation de ces
festivals est-ce qu'il y a eu un manque
d'anticipation ou est-ce que dans votre
calendrier un peu moins de deux ans ça
suffit pour redresser là-bas non en fait
je pense qu'effectivement il y a eu un
manque d'anticipation un peu globale
alors elle a décharge tout le monde on
est sorti d'une période un peu un peu
compliquée avec cette crise sanitaire
qui a occupé tout le monde et mobilisé
toutes les énergies nous on avait bien
anticipé la question de la difficulté
d'accéder aux Arena et au stade puisque
les Arenas et les stades avaient informé
les producteurs de spectacle en revanche
sur la question des festivals
définitivement ce sujet n'était pas
arrivé sur dans le cadre de nos
discussions avec le ministère de la
Culture même si on savait que sur le
territoire parisien il y aurait des
difficultés certes mais on avait
absolument pas envisagé que cela
impacterait l'ensemble du territoire
français même dans des dans des endroits
où il n'y a absolument pas de
manifestations sportives donc on a vécu
ça en effet un peu comme comme une
annonce assez violente une sidération du
secteur puisqu'on s'est dit mais tout le
monde n'ira pas à Paris suivre les
manifestations des Jeux Olympiques et
les Français seront privés de festival
dans les territoires or c'est quand même
ils sont très attachés alors festival
Les Français donc mais quelque part vous
avez raison monsieur le sénateur je
pense qu'il a aussi bousculé bousculer
le calendrier nous a obligé à réagir
nous on a immédiatement sévi saisi la
ministre de la Culture qui a réuni
l'ensemble du secteur nous avons
travaillé et on a permis d'aboutir à
cette circulaire qui est un cadre au
moins qui nous donne un texte qui sera
opposable dans le cadre de problèmes
ultérieurs donc maintenant à nous
effectivement d'avancer de faire en
sorte que le moins de festivals possible
soit annulé et que ceux qui sont annulés
ne soient pas juste oubliés et qu'on
prenne en considération leur préjudice
parce que même si c'est une décision qui
sera justifiée au regard de tous ces
textes et du fait qu'il y a les JO il y
a quand même un préjudice qu'il faudra
réparer ah moi je pense que parler cette
circulaire et qu'on parle de territoire
il y a un grand pouvoir qui est laissé
au préfet dans cette circulaire est-ce
que pour vous c'est une bonne chose
alors c'est c'est une bonne chose en
même temps il faut qu'on soit vigilance
une bonne chose parce que les préfets
dans les territoires connaissent très
bien leur territoire connaissent très
bien leur manifestations donc
effectivement il y a un rapport très
régulier entre les organisateurs de
festival et le préfet puisque c'est lui
qui autorise la manifestation donc ça
c'est très positif après nous souhaitons
c'est pour ça que nous nous supportons
cette demande d'un comité multiplication
de personnes différentes qui peuvent
intervenir sur des décisions et donc il
faut qu'il y ait une cohérence dans les
décisions qui soient prises c'est pour
ça qu'on sera vigilant à cet égard c'est
une bonne chose pour vous Claude Kern
que ce soit les préfets avec Malika
segunolody qui connaissent bien les
territoires mais en même temps est-ce
qu'il y a un risque d'inégalité
territoriale alors c'est toujours la
problématique de l'interprétation des
textes et
il faut effectivement
être vigilant là-dessus je suis tout à
fait d'accord en règle générale les
préfets connaissent très bien les
territoires
connaissent très bien et les problèmes
de sécurité donc là dessus il va falloir
être vigilant je rebondis peut-être sur
d'autres manifestations qui auront lieu
en même temps je prends l'exemple du
Tour de France dans le il y a eu un
accord puisque le l'arrivée du Tour de
France aura bien lieu le 21 juillet mais
à Nice cette fois-ci donc là aussi c'est
une manifestation qui nécessite beaucoup
de force de sécurité mobile et pour
trouver des solutions nous avons
rencontré d'ailleurs Christian Prudhomme
à ce sujet qui nous expliquait que le
Tour de France en 2024 il y aura pas mal
d'étapes qui seront limitera au fait
avec la France et dont les forces de
sécurité mobile des pays voisins seront
mobilisés notamment l'Italie
en Italie en 2024 Jean-Jacques Lauzac
sur ce qu'on disait sur la question des
préfets est-ce que ça vous rassure ou
est-ce que ça vous inquiète est-ce que
vous dites du coup il y aura peut-être
pas égalité territoriale sur tout le
territoire non je crois qu'il faut
trouver là aussi si je peux dire en
terme de méthodologie injuste équilibre
moi je suis pas du tout opposé bien au
contraire et de vision un traitement
tout à fait territorialisé délocalisé au
plus près des réalités quotidiennes mais
de notre côté il faut aussi qu'il y ait
une harmonie nationale pour qu'il n'y
ait pas de discrimination entre les
différents organisateurs entre les
différents territoires je crois que
c'est un sujet essentiel parce qu'il y a
quand même une expression d'ailleurs que
l'on n'a pas encore employé depuis le
début de notre émission et qui est parti
prenante de ces de ces Jeux olympiques
et paralympiques ce sont les Olympiades
culturelles les Olympiens culturels donc
effectivement je crois que notamment en
termes de communication il faut assez
rapidement peut-être que là aussi il y a
un manque d'anticipation donc il faut
procéder à un rattrapage peut-être que
là aussi il faut rapidement donner du le
contenu à cette expression olympiade
culturelle notamment vis-à-vis du grand
public ça fait partie aussi des intérêts
de l'organisation des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques les dernières 30 secondes
pour vous mais elle est cassée Guino
quel message vous avez envie de faire
passer au ministre et au sénateur de
nous permettre effectivement d'exister
en 2024 je pense que les Français aiment
leur festival aiment le sport même leur
festivalent également et ce sera le
message un beau message merci beaucoup
[Musique]